That boy needs therapy. Psychosomatic. That boy needs therapy. You're psychosomatic. That boy needs therapy. Lie down on the couch. That boy needs therapy. Hey guys, it's Joel with the Taproot Therapy Collective podcast, and today I'm going to be reading an article called Icky, Mean, and Hateful on the nature of evil in psychotherapy. It's a longer article. If it's easier for you to read something like this, I recommend you check out our website at www.gettherapybirmingham.com.
那个男孩需要治疗。身心失调。那个男孩需要治疗。你这是身心失调。那个男孩需要治疗。躺在沙发上。那个男孩需要治疗。大家好，我是Taproot Therapy Collective播客的乔尔，今天我要读一篇文章，题目是《讨厌、刻薄与可恨：心理治疗中关于邪恶的本质》。这是一篇较长的文章。如果阅读这类文章对你来说更容易，我建议你访问我们的网站 www.gettherapybirmingham.com。
Navigate to the tab where it says blog and read it where you can find this and other articles that are not available on the podcast. I don't record every article. And so the article begins. One of the things that happens frequently in family therapy is that a person or a group of family members will accuse the other person or group of family members of being mean or hateful. Now, most of the time, if someone is abusive or they are intentionally hurtful, they won't deny that they have ill intentions. They think the other person deserves it, and they'll make that clear in therapy. So put simply, someone who has meant to be mean will usually admit that when they're accused of it. Other times, one side denies intentionally trying to hurt the person,
导航到标有“博客”的标签页，在那里你可以找到这篇文章以及其他播客中没有的文章。我并没有录制每一篇文章。文章就这样开始了。家庭治疗中经常发生的一件事是，一个人或一组家庭成员会指责另一个人或另一组家庭成员刻薄或可恨。通常情况下，如果有人具有虐待倾向或故意伤人，他们不会否认自己有恶意。他们认为对方罪有应得，并且会在治疗中明确表达这一点。简而言之，一个存心刻薄的人在被指责时通常会承认这一点。而在其他时候，一方会否认自己有意伤害对方，
accusing them of trying to cause harm, and they say they didn't mean to hurt them. So when this happens, I draw a line down a piece of paper, and I have each side write down what they remember was said, you know, the hateful thing. So on one side of the paper, there will be an objective statement, and these statements might include something like, you drank too much and you yelled at me, or you spent more money than you said you would, or you didn't do what you told me you would. And then on the other side, there will be a subjective statement, which is what the other person remembers, who's calling the first person mean or hateful. And it will have something that is subjective, usually something like this. You said I'm obnoxious, or you said I'm stupid and I can't
指责对方试图造成伤害，并声称他们并非有意伤害对方。所以当这种情况发生时，我会在一张纸上画一条线，让双方写下他们记得对方说过的话，也就是那些伤人的话。纸的一侧会写下一个客观陈述，这些陈述可能包括：“你喝多了，对我大吼大叫”，或者“你花的钱比你说的要多”，或者“你没有做你答应过我的事”。而在另一侧，会写下一个主观陈述，这是指责对方刻薄或可恨的那个人所记忆的内容。它会包含一些主观的东西，通常是这样的：“你说我令人讨厌”，或者“你说我愚蠢，我不会
do math. So these statements refer to the same event, but each party hears two different things. So when we don't want to grow or change, when other people offer us criticism, you know, constructive or not, or they just ask us nicely to change, we view them asking us to change our behavior as an attack, because we don't believe that they can't. We view it as a judgment, which is why that second column is full of subjective statements. So when someone points out that I went over budget, it's easier for me to feel like they are in the wrong for making me feel stupid than accepting that I could change the behavior or learn new things. And when I get drunk, it's easier for me to think that someone is judging me
做数学题”。所以这些陈述指的是同一件事，但双方听到的却是两码事。因此，当我们不想成长或改变时，当别人向我们提出批评（无论是否具有建设性），或者只是友好地要求我们改变时，我们会把他们要求我们改变行为视为一种攻击，因为我们不相信他们不能这样做。我们将其视为一种评判，这就是为什么第二栏里充满了主观陈述。所以当有人指出我超支时，比起接受我可以改变行为或学习新事物，我更容易觉得是他们错了，因为他们让我感到自己很蠢。而当我喝醉时，比起承认我犯了错并感到内疚或羞愧，我更容易认为有人在评判我，
than it is to admit that I made a mistake and maybe feel some guilt or shame. So, you know, I tell clients often in psychotherapy that avoiding conflict does not make them a good person. If you're avoided at all and you've come to therapy with me, you've heard that. So often what avoidance does, or avoiding conflict or difficult conversations, or even avoiding being assertive, and the worst is avoiding what we know is true in our own head. We can't even think it. Your therapist is just asking you to think it, and you can't do that.
而不是承认我犯了错，并可能感到一些内疚或羞耻。所以，你知道，我在心理治疗中经常告诉客户，逃避冲突并不能让你成为一个好人。如果你有逃避倾向，并且来找我做过治疗，你一定听过这句话。逃避、逃避冲突或困难的对话，甚至逃避表现得坚定，最糟糕的是逃避我们内心深处明知是真实的事情，这些行为往往会带来什么后果呢？我们甚至连想都不敢想。你的治疗师只是要求你去思考它，而你却做不到。
That makes us enablers of bad behavior, and it makes us contributors to the problematic state of this world. It makes us contribute to evil when we are avoidant. And one of the ways that we do this is by pretending that the truth is always in the middle of each conflict, and that all perspectives are equally valid. This is avoidance, because holding the authority to judge one side versus another makes you feel icky or judgy. You know, you were around people who were judgmental. You don't want to be like that. Well, you're not. If you're being assertive, you're just being honest. We want life to be this children's movie where all conflict is just a misunderstanding between two benevolent parties,
这使我们成为不良行为的助长者，也使我们成为这个世界问题状态的推手。当我们逃避时，我们就在助长邪恶。我们这样做的方式之一是假装每个冲突的真相总是处于中间地带，并且所有观点都同样有效。这是一种逃避，因为持有评判一方而非另一方的权力会让你感到不舒服或像个评判者。你知道，你身边曾有过爱评判别人的人。你不想成为那样的人。好吧，你并不是。如果你表现得坚定，你只是在诚实。我们希望生活像一部儿童电影，所有的冲突都只是两个仁慈方之间的误解，
and both sides have a good point. And sometimes that's true, but that is not always true, and trying to turn all conflict into that just isn't life. It's not adult. Sometimes people do say and believe things that are just wrong. Each person could have a valuable perspective, and they could make a unique contribution to our collective reality, but the operative word here is could. Not everyone chooses to. And if you're pretending that everyone will or everyone was, I don't know that that's
双方都有道理。有时确实如此，但这并不总是事实，试图把所有冲突都变成那样并不是生活。那不成熟。有时人们确实会说出并相信一些完全错误的事情。每个人都可以有有价值的观点，他们可以为我们的集体现实做出独特的贡献，但这里的关键词是“可以”。并非每个人都选择这样做。如果你假装每个人都会这样做，或者每个人都曾经这样做，我不知道这是否
honest or going to help you get anywhere in family or individual therapy. Any person's validity of perspective is predicated on that person's ability to be honest with themselves. How can I be honest with anyone if I can't even look in the mirror and be honest with myself? If you can't be honest with yourself or accept objective reality, you know, things that are just true about something, then every word that you say about that thing or that topic that you can't be honest with yourself about is a lie, whether or
诚实，或者在家庭或个人治疗中是否有助于你取得任何进展。任何人的观点是否有效，取决于此人对自己诚实的能力。如果我连照镜子对自己诚实都做不到，我又怎么能对任何人诚实呢？如果你不能对自己诚实或接受客观现实（即关于某事确实是真的事情），那么你所说的关于那个你无法对自己诚实的事件或话题的每一个字都是谎言，无论
not you mean it to me. It may be an unconscious lie. A lot of people say, well, the person doesn't know that it wasn't true. And it's like, well, they were there. You both saw the same thing. What do you mean? Yeah, but they just don't know it. And I understand what they mean. They mean that that person is just kind of unconsciously panicking and refusing to let themselves know something that is true because it makes them feel icky or judgy or whatever. It doesn't matter if you mean to be lying or not. If you pretend that unconscious or unintentional dishonesty is just a perspective somebody has, and that deserves our consideration, you know, and everyone needs to consider this and treat, you know, something that's true and something that's false as equally valid just because this person has a feeling about it, you know, that is an absurd
你是否有意为之。这可能是一个无意识的谎言。很多人说：“好吧，那个人不知道那不是真的。”这就像是说：“好吧，他们当时在场。你们俩看到了同样的事情。你是什么意思？”“是的，但他们就是不知道。”我明白他们的意思。他们的意思是，那个人只是在无意识地恐慌，拒绝让自己知道某些真实的事情，因为它让他们感到不舒服、像个评判者或诸如此类。你是否有意撒谎并不重要。如果你假装无意识或非故意的虚假陈述只是某人的一个观点，并且这值得我们考虑，你知道，每个人都需要考虑这一点，并把真实和虚假的东西视为同样有效，仅仅因为这个人对此有某种感觉，你知道，这是一个荒谬的
proposition. Yet, you know, most people do this all the time, and just so that they don't have to feel mean. And I'm not advocating when I'm saying this for you to pass self-righteous judgment or throw out discernment and humility. The opposite of truth is not lies, but it's certainty. And judgment is unhealthy when it comes from an unresolved superiority complex. You know, when comes from an unresolved superiority complex. You know, when you have an unresolved superiority complex, you judge other people all the time just so that you don't have to feel inferior. And a lot of times people who don't want to pass judgment, they've been hurt by someone like that, and they're like, well, I'm not going to be like
命题。然而，你知道，大多数人一直在这样做，仅仅是为了不让自己感到刻薄。我这么说并不是在提倡你进行自以为是的评判，或者抛弃洞察力和谦逊。真理的对立面不是谎言，而是确定性。当评判源于未解决的优越感时，它是不健康的。你知道，当你有一种未解决的优越感时，你一直在评判别人，只是为了不让自己感到自卑。很多时候，那些不想进行评判的人，曾被那样的人伤害过，他们会说：“好吧，我才不要像
them, so I'm just going to not admit reality to myself. Well, that's a little bit too far. If reality is hurting somebody's feelings, that's not your fault. Judgment is a part of mature adulthood. When we allow our intuition to tell us that some things are simply wrong, no matter how widely accepted or traditional they are, they just are not right. Moral certainty is one of the first stones on the path to fanaticism. So I'm not saying that you should never doubt yourself, but having just a moral clarity, that's an essential ingredient to
他们那样，所以我干脆不向自己承认现实。”好吧，这有点过头了。如果现实伤害了某人的感情，那不是你的错。评判是成熟成年生活的一部分。当我们允许直觉告诉我们某些事情就是错误的，无论它们被多么广泛地接受或多么传统，它们就是不对。道德确定性是通往狂热之路上的第一块基石。所以我并不是说你不应该怀疑自己，但拥有道德清晰度是心理健康的一个基本要素，
mental health because you're just able to know clearly what you know and apply the same standard that you have for yourself to others and vice versa. Now we can never wield judgment or discernment as a tool that helps us make healthy decisions and avoid destructive paths if we get overwhelmed by guilt every time we start to notice that other people are behaving badly sometimes. And even people we love or people that helped us are all the reasons that we use to not notice that. We just don't let ourselves see it. Many times when we talk about psychology, politics, religion, or family honesty, or family honestly and openly, it makes people feel icky or guilty. And this is because most people do not want to know what they think when it comes to these arenas of life, or they don't want to accept what they already know.
因为你能够清楚地知道自己所知，并将你对自己适用的标准同样应用于他人，反之亦然。如果我们每次注意到别人有时表现不佳时都被内疚感淹没，我们就永远无法运用评判或洞察力作为工具来帮助我们做出健康的决定并避免破坏性的道路。即使是我们爱的人或帮助过我们的人，所有这些都是我们用来不去注意这些的理由。我们只是不让自己看到它。很多时候，当我们谈论心理学、政治、宗教或家庭诚实，或者坦诚开放地谈论家庭时，这会让人们感到不舒服或内疚。这是因为大多数人不想知道自己在生活的这些领域中到底在想什么，或者他们不想接受他们已经知道的事实。
Carl Jung talked about it a lot, the psychologist, he calls this the shadow. The slippery half-truth that we tell ourselves so that we don't have to accept the whole truth that always walks behind us. And often this is because of trauma, this kind of dishonesty, because we don't want to hurt others by criticizing them because we were hurt as children. We don't want to be like the abuser, so we decide that we're either going to play victim or we're going to enable a victim. And the second one, enabling the victim, is more common than somebody who has kind of a victim mindset or like a personality disorder. And that's one of the ways that we don't notice that trauma is still running our lives. You know, we just make it easier to believe that everything is our fault or enable
卡尔·荣格经常谈论这一点，这位心理学家称之为“阴影”。我们告诉自己的那种滑溜溜的半真半假的话，是为了不必接受那始终跟在我们身后的全部真相。通常这是由于创伤，这种不诚实，因为我们不想通过批评他人来伤害他们，因为我们小时候受过伤害。我们不想成为施虐者，所以我们决定要么扮演受害者，要么助长受害者。而后者，即助长受害者，比那种有受害者心态或人格障碍的人更常见。这是我们没有注意到创伤仍在支配我们生活的方式之一。你知道，我们只是让相信一切都是我们的错变得更容易，或者通过拒绝指出他人不健康或自我毁灭的倾向来助长
other people's bad behavior by refusing to point out unhealthy or self-destructive tendencies in others, which as an adult is your job, you know, to point out to people who you love and are not trying to enable when they're being unhealthy and when they're being self-destructive. But that starts with you being honest about that in your own head. So if we're afraid of judgment, we think that we can avoid it, but instead our avoidance causes more problems. Instead of having frank conversations about where our beliefs diverge from others, we try and control others through praise. You know, telling somebody that we love them because they make good grades is just as damaging as saying, I won't love you if you make bad grades. They're kind of the same statement.
他人的不良行为，而作为一个成年人，你的工作就是指出你所爱的人在不健康和自我毁灭时的行为，前提是你并没有试图助长他们。但这始于你在自己脑海中对此保持诚实。所以如果我们害怕评判，我们认为我们可以避免它，但实际上我们的逃避导致了更多的问题。我们没有就我们的信仰与他人的分歧进行坦诚的对话，而是试图通过赞美来控制他人。你知道，告诉某人我们爱他们是因为他们成绩好，和说“如果你成绩不好我就不爱你了”一样具有破坏性。它们本质上是同一句话。
You know, telling someone that, you know, we like them because they do certain things is still judgment. Sidra and Hal Stone in their book, Embracing Ourselves, they talk about how most judgment is passed through positive statements. It's passed through praise. And that still does damage to children when they show up in therapy as adults. Other times, and that's because it makes the love sound conditional. And then children are just as afraid as if you told them that you weren't proud of them or, you know, something else. So other times, this unconscious fear of holding authority or passing judgment blinds us to the judgments that we do hold and pass all the time. And so many people are unaware that
你知道，告诉某人我们喜欢他们是因为他们做了某些事情，这仍然是评判。西德拉和哈尔·斯通在他们的书《拥抱我们自己》中谈到，大多数评判是通过积极的陈述传递的。它是通过赞美传递的。当这些孩子成年后出现在治疗中时，这仍然会造成伤害。其他时候，这是因为这让爱听起来是有条件的。然后孩子们会感到害怕，就像你告诉他们你不为他们感到骄傲，或者其他什么一样。所以其他时候，这种对持有权威或进行评判的无意识恐惧，使我们对自己一直持有并传递的评判视而不见。所以很多人没有意识到
they hold judgment because they have identified with it for so long as just a part of who they are. And sometimes these individuals grew up in families where they may not have even realized that they were being constantly passively criticized. And that's because the places where we were taught to criticize ourselves, and often we hide an unhealed wound there, we don't notice that what we're saying to our children or to someone else is damaging. And so the things are people who we judge very intensely. They have potential to become important teachers for us
他们持有评判，因为他们长期以来一直将其视为自己的一部分。有时这些人成长在这样的家庭中，他们甚至可能没有意识到自己一直在受到持续的被动批评。这是因为我们被教导批评自己的地方，往往隐藏着一个未愈合的伤口，我们没有注意到我们对孩子或其他人所说的话是有害的。所以，那些我们非常强烈地评判的人，他们有潜力成为我们重要的老师，
because we can learn why we need to other this person, why we need to judge them. And you can mindfully find out if that is something where you have a trauma and an unconscious bias that's making you be judgmental, or if that's just something that's true about life that you should accept. But when you find yourself having an extreme emotional reaction to somebody, that maybe is a good sign that there's some shadow projection there and that they may be an important teacher for you. It doesn't make them a good person. It makes your experience with them a lesson. So when we have these unconscious biases, we often can't see them and we can't apply our values consistently until we can see them.
因为我们可以了解为什么我们需要将此人“他者化”，为什么我们需要评判他们。你可以有意识地找出这是否是因为你有创伤和无意识偏见导致你变得爱评判，或者这只是关于生活的真相，你应该接受它。但当你发现自己对某人有极端的负面情绪反应时，这可能是一个很好的迹象，表明那里存在某种阴影投射，他们可能对你来说是一位重要的老师。这并不意味着他们是个好人。这让你的经历成为了一堂课。所以当我们有这些无意识偏见时，我们往往看不到它们，也无法一致地应用我们的价值观，直到我们能看到它们。
We apply values in the abstract, but we ignore our values when we are looking friends, family, or patients in the eye. Maybe this avoidance is worse in the bless-her-heart American South where I live, but it's something about it seems very old and very human. You know, I encounter that when I read ancient history too. So it seems that many people who are afraid to grow and change will accuse others of being hateful and judgmental or mean for just pointing out reality to them. And this goes back to the subjective and objective statements from therapy. You know, those people who are attacking an objective statement and turning it subjective, they do that because they do not want anyone to point out their own hidden mistakes and insecurities. And Remember, fear of judgment always comes from
我们在抽象层面应用价值观，但当我们看着朋友、家人或病人的眼睛时，却忽略了我们的价值观。也许这种逃避在“愿上帝保佑”的美国南方（我住的地方）更严重，但它似乎非常古老且非常人性化。你知道，我在阅读古代历史时也遇到过这种情况。所以，许多害怕成长和改变的人，会指责那些只是向他们指出现实的人是可恨、爱评判或刻薄的。这又回到了治疗中的主观和客观陈述。你知道，那些攻击客观陈述并将其转为主观的人，他们这样做是因为他们不希望任何人指出他们自己隐藏的错误和不安全感。记住，对评判的恐惧总是源于
this unresolved wound. When you hold authority comfortably, you know, people with this unconscious wound will always react negatively to you. And you're just holding authority that you have to pass, you know, a knowledge of right and wrong over your life. But that's going to make someone who has a fear of judgment react very negatively. Because even if you're saying something that's correct about another person, they're still going to see that as an attack on them. Because if that person could change, you're telling me I could change too, but I don't think I can change. So you just pointing out what that person did, maybe having an opinion about it, that's an attack on me. Sorry, man, you did something wrong there. And you may have felt that energy from certain
这种未解决的伤口。当你舒适地持有权威时，你知道，有这种无意识伤口的人总是会消极地回应你。而你只是在持有你必须传递的权威，你知道，一种关于你生活中是非对错的知识。但这会让一个对评判有恐惧的人反应非常消极。因为即使你说的关于另一个人的话是正确的，他们仍然会将其视为对他们的攻击。因为如果那个人能改变，你就是在告诉我我也能改变，但我认为我不能改变。所以你只是指出那个人做了什么，也许对此有某种看法，那对我来说就是一种攻击。抱歉，伙计，你在那件事上做错了。你可能从你生活中的某些
people in your life because they would rather have their faults ignored and enabled. And so they want you to do that for other people when you talk about them. Sometimes it's everyone. Sometimes it's certain kinds of people. Sometimes it's males, females, you know, whatever. But you see people who have a consistent reaction to you pointing out something about a certain kind of person, notice that. So when you tell someone how their behavior affected you in family therapy, you'll often hear things like, well, you must think you're perfect if you're going to point out something that's honest and true about me. And we don't have to be perfect in order to point out failure. You know, being moral means having integrity means you're
人身上感受到了那种能量，因为他们宁愿自己的错误被忽视和助长。所以当你在谈论他们时，他们希望你对其他人也这样做。有时是所有人。有时是某些类型的人。有时是男性、女性，等等。但你会看到人们对你指出关于某类人的事情有持续的反应，注意这一点。所以当你在家庭治疗中告诉某人他们的行为如何影响你时，你经常会听到这样的话：“好吧，如果你要指出关于我诚实且真实的事情，那你一定认为自己很完美。”我们不需要完美才能指出失败。你知道，有道德意味着有正直，意味着你
pointing out your failures at the same rate that you're pointing out other people. That they occur. You're not pretending that everybody else makes the same amount of mistakes. You're just being honest about mistakes when they happen, including your own. If somebody is criticizing other people, but they don't think they ever do anything wrong, that's a good place to maybe notice that this is going on. You probably want to not accept advice from people who think that they are perfect, and you definitely don't want to accept criticism or feel bad about the judgment of somebody who has never said sorry to anyone, because it's probably not constructive criticism. They're probably projecting on you. So, you know, trying to avoid judgment of other people is not a virtue. It's a sin.
指出你的失败的频率和你指出别人失败的频率是一样的。它们发生了。你不是假装别人犯的错误和你一样多。你只是在错误发生时诚实地面对它们，包括你自己的。如果有人在批评别人，但他们认为自己从不做错任何事，那是一个很好的地方，可以注意到这种情况正在发生。你可能不想接受那些认为自己完美的人的建议，而且你绝对不想接受那些从未向任何人道歉的人的批评，或者因为他们的评判而感到难过，因为那可能不是建设性的批评。他们可能是在把你当作投射对象。所以，你知道，试图避免对别人的评判并不是一种美德。这是一种罪过。
You know, we owe it to ourselves and others not to carry water for bad behavior and solve destructive patterns. Loving others is giving them what they need, not what they want. And what we need is not always a gift that we want right now. There's a beautiful passage in a case study I read a long time ago. And this lady, her husband was dead and she was dying of cancer, but she had these young children. And because she was dying of cancer, she had an oxygen machine and these different machines. And the kids were too young to understand. They're like four and five. And it was just very sad that they're going to lose their mom in a couple months. They were going to lose their mother. And so the mother's therapist told her, you need to go be with the children. And she said,
你知道，我们有义务对自己和他人负责，不为不良行为背书，不解决破坏性模式。爱他人是给他们所需要的，而不是他们想要的。而我们所需要的并不总是我们现在想要的礼物。我很久以前读过一个案例研究，里面有一段美丽的段落。这位女士，她的丈夫去世了，她自己也患了癌症，但她有年幼的孩子。因为她患有癌症，她有氧气机和这些不同的机器。孩子们太小了，无法理解。他们才四五岁。他们几个月后就要失去妈妈了，这非常令人难过。他们要失去母亲了。所以母亲的治疗师告诉她：“你需要去和孩子们在一起。”她说，
well, I'm not going to be around them because when I'm around them, they scream and they get upset because they don't recognize me. They don't recognize these machines. I look sick. It freaks them out. And she said, no, no, no, you need to be there and you need to be loving and you need to get them used to you because you're giving them a gift, but it is not a gift that they want right now. You need to be the mother in the mind of a 30 or 40 year old man who is remembering what his mother treated him like when he was five, because you won't be there to see all that stuff. So they don't get this gift right now. They don't want it, but you need to give it to them because that's what parenting is. And that affected me. I really think about that a lot. You know, am I giving somebody what they want to feel good about myself
“好吧，我不会和他们在一起，因为当我和他们在一起时，他们会尖叫，会心烦意乱，因为他们认不出我。他们认不出这些机器。我看起来很病态。这让他们感到害怕。”治疗师说：“不，不，不，你需要在那儿，你需要充满爱，你需要让他们习惯你，因为你是在给他们一份礼物，但这并不是他们现在想要的礼物。你需要成为一个30或40岁男人心目中的母亲，他会记得他五岁时母亲是如何对待他的，因为你到时候不在场去见证这一切。所以他们现在得不到这份礼物。他们不想要它，但你需要给他们，因为这就是为人父母的意义。”这触动了我。我真的经常思考这个问题。你知道，我是为了让自己感觉良好而给某人他们想要的，
or am I giving them what they need because I'm being moral? So it's our job to give honesty as a gift. And others can open that gift if they want, but they don't have to. And if somebody does not want your constructive criticism, then don't offer it. You know, don't cut them slack in your own head or insist that others cut slack for them. My critique in this article is not very much about the way we behave. It's not really about behavior as much as the way that we think. Most of us are afraid of being judgmental. And when you give up your right to judgment, when you're letting people around you slide because it won't be worth it, they'll blow up, or you're letting them slide because, well, you know, I did bad things once and and I don't want anyone to point that out, so I'm going to let this slide because
还是因为我很有道德而给他们他们所需要的？所以我们的工作是把诚实作为礼物给予。其他人如果愿意可以打开这份礼物，但他们不必这样做。如果某人不需要你的建设性批评，那就不要提供。你知道，不要在自己脑海中对他们宽容，也不要坚持让别人对他们宽容。我在本文中的批评并不是关于我们的行为方式。它与其说是关于行为，不如说是关于我们的思维方式。我们大多数人都害怕被评判。当你放弃你的评判权时，当你让周围的人随心所欲，因为这不值得，他们会爆发，或者你让他们随心所欲，因为“好吧，我曾经做过坏事，我不想让任何人指出这一点，所以我打算让这件事过去，因为
I don't think I can be forgiven, so I'll just unconditionally forgive everyone else. If you're doing it for some kind of reason that's about unresolved trauma, then you are not acting with integrity. You have a responsibility to discern and apply your own moral authority to life. As an adult, you have that responsibility to apply your own moral authority. Not what is traditional, not what you were taught is right, not what other people say is right, but the things that you have actually learned are effective, that make you feel better and that make you grow. And you cannot function as an adult without this ability. You have a lot of adults that act like children in this world. And that may sound like I'm being mean or judgmental, but look at this world. I mean,
我不认为我能被原谅，所以我将无条件地原谅所有人。”如果你是因为某种与未解决的创伤有关的原因而这样做，那么你的行为就没有正直可言。你有责任去辨别并将你自己的道德权威应用于生活。作为一个成年人，你有责任应用你自己的道德权威。不是传统的，不是你被教导什么是对的，不是别人说什么是对的，而是你实际上学到的有效的、让你感觉更好并让你成长的事情。没有这种能力，你就无法作为一个成年人运作。这个世界上有很多成年人表现得像孩子。这听起来可能是我在刻薄或评判，但看看这个世界。我的意思是，
look at the people that we platform. I mean, are you kidding? If you can't be honest about that, then read this article five more times. Because most adults do not grow into the capacity to be adults, you know, and I haven't in a lot of ways that I'm honest about with my family, my therapist, my friends. Send me an email. I'll be honest with you if you want. But, you know, if you cannot ask yourself, is this world and myself better off for this decision with clarity and know that you behaving this way is actually making you better off and the world better off, then you're avoiding a pretty big part of mature adulthood and a big part of knowing who you are. Avoidance is not mature. even if you don't get it, even if other people don't get it, if you know that my decision to go into this field or my decision to, you know, confront this person or whatever is going on is better for me and the world is better for it too, then why not do it? You know,
看看我们所支持的那些人。我的意思是，你在开玩笑吗？如果你不能对此诚实，那就把这篇文章再读五遍。因为大多数成年人并没有成长为成年人的能力，你知道，而且我在很多方面都没有，我对此对我的家人、我的治疗师、我的朋友都很诚实。给我发封邮件。如果你愿意，我会对你诚实。但是，你知道，如果你不能问自己：“这个决定是否让这个世界和我自己变得更好？”并清楚地知道你这样做实际上让你变得更好，世界也变得更好，那么你就是在逃避成熟成年生活的一个相当大的部分，也是了解你是谁的一个重要部分。逃避是不成熟的。即使你不明白，即使其他人不明白，如果你知道我进入这个领域的决定，或者我面对这个人的决定，或者无论发生了什么，对我来说更好，世界也因此变得更好，那么为什么不这样做呢？你知道，
one of the only reasons why you wouldn't would be something like fear, which is not really a good reason to make decisions based solely on being afraid. So ignoring these realities of life, it leaves you neurotically reliving childhood, which most people do. And I'll admit that healthy and unhealthy behavior can look the same from the outside. Some people criticize others just to deflect judgment off their own flaws. And this is an example of a person who is avoiding admitting the things that it is their job to change and grow through. They want everyone else to look bad so that they don't have to look at themselves.
你不会这样做的唯一原因之一可能是恐惧，这并不是仅仅基于恐惧来做决定的好理由。所以忽视这些生活现实，会让你神经质地重温童年，大多数人都是这样。我承认健康和不健康的行为从外面看起来可能是一样的。有些人批评别人只是为了转移对自己缺点的评判。这是一个正在逃避承认那些他们有责任去改变和成长的事情的人的例子。他们希望其他人看起来很糟糕，这样他们就不必审视自己。
What's the quote in the Bible about, you know, there's a speck of sawdust in your eye, or you see the speck of sawdust in your brother's eye, but really you have a blog coming out of your own. You know, so to others, the same criticism may be, you know, a good faith attempt to offer somebody constructive criticism on where they hurt others needlessly, and that person has diverged from their stated values. So constructive and unconstructive criticism can look the same. Somebody can be saying the same thing. I'm kind of of the opinion that you can do anything in a healthy way or an unhealthy way.
圣经里关于“你眼中有一根木刺，或者你看到你兄弟眼中的木屑，但实际上你自己眼中有一根梁木”的引语是什么？你知道，所以对其他人来说，同样的批评可能是一个善意的尝试，去给某人提供建设性的批评，指出他们在哪里不必要地伤害了他人，而那个人已经偏离了他们所宣称的价值观。所以建设性和非建设性的批评看起来可能是一样的。某人可能在说同样的话。我倾向于认为你可以以健康或不健康的方式做任何事情。
You can't always tell the difference from behavior. You need to know the person and the motivation. And so some people who criticize you consider the criticism, but it's not valid. It's not about you. It's their perspective. And other people, even though you really want to point out everything that they did wrong in their life, you really want to say, yeah, but notice if that criticism is right. Even people attacking you for the wrong reasons can be important teachers. So this kind of dealing with judgment, this is hard
你不能总是从行为上看出区别。你需要了解这个人及其动机。所以有些人批评你，你可以考虑这种批评，但它并不成立。这与你无关。这是他们的观点。而其他人，即使你真的很想指出他们生活中所做的一切错误，你真的很想说：“是的，但要注意这种批评是否正确。”即使是那些因为错误原因攻击你的人，也可能成为重要的老师。所以这种处理评判的方式，这很难
to tell apart in ourselves and in other people. And for me, therapy was very beneficial because I was able, it helped me build this ability in myself because, you know, I finally had a therapist who wouldn't let me entertain her and wouldn't let me turn, you know, control a narrative. She was able to listen to what I was feeling. And when I would run into the woods with thinking, she could push me back into what I was feeling. And that allowed me to face it. And then that allowed me to be a little bit more honest about when emotion was what was running my mouth and not my brain. So, you know, Alfred Adler, psychologist Alfred Adler,
在我们自己和他人身上区分开来。对我来说，治疗非常有益，因为它帮助我在自己身上建立了这种能力，因为，你知道，我终于有了一位不会让我取悦她，也不会让我控制叙事的治疗师。她能够倾听我的感受。当我思维跑偏时，她能把我推回到我的感受中。这让我能够面对它。然后这让我能够更诚实地面对什么时候是情绪在支配我的嘴，而不是我的大脑。所以，你知道，阿尔弗雷德·阿德勒，心理学家阿尔弗雷德·阿德勒，
there's a good article about him on the blog if you want to go to that. He said that all problems in mental health come from somebody not wanting to do one of two things. One, help other people. Two, wait till they ask you for the help. So this article is not defending your right to punish or antagonize. Other people's decisions are theirs and they're not for you to change or obsess over. Again, this article is mostly about what you think. We don't always try and, you know, go in and spank the person or hold them to account. Sometimes somebody might, but mainly we just
博客上有一篇关于他的好文章，如果你想去看的话。他说，心理健康的所有问题都源于某人不想做两件事中的一件。第一，帮助别人。第二，等到他们向你寻求帮助。所以这篇文章并不是在捍卫你惩罚或对抗的权利。其他人的决定是他们自己的，不是让你去改变或沉迷的。再说一次，这篇文章主要是关于你的想法。我们并不总是试图去责备那个人或让他们负责。有时某人可能会，但主要是我们只是
obsess about how these people are doing it all wrong. Well, you know, we're wasting our own life. You don't have the right to obsess, or at least you don't have the right. You don't have permission from me. That's not what I'm saying to do. You can obsess and you can't change the behavior of your parents, your friends, especially not your patients. Remember what Alfred Adler said, one, help people, two, wait till they ask you to help them. And this is the first step of the change process. You know, instead of that, you know, this article is about allowing clarity in your own communication and thinking. Unless somebody asks you for help in their moral development and growth, then leave them alone. Unless somebody asks you for help with their decisions and moral dishonesty,
沉迷于这些人是如何把一切都搞砸的。好吧，你知道，我们在浪费自己的生命。你没有权利沉迷，或者至少你没有权利。你没有得到我的许可。我不是让你那样做。你可以沉迷，但你无法改变你的父母、你的朋友，尤其是你的病人的行为。记住阿尔弗雷德·阿德勒说的话，第一，帮助别人，第二，等到他们向你寻求帮助。这是改变过程的第一步。你知道，与其那样，这篇文章是关于在你的沟通和思考中允许清晰。除非有人向你寻求道德发展和成长方面的帮助，否则就别管他们。除非有人向你寻求关于他们的决定和道德不诚实的帮助，
that's not any of your business. You have no right to enforce your morals on the world. You know, many sessions of therapy with me end when I just tell people, look, you're making a case that you deserve to feel better, and I absolutely believe that, and that you deserve, I think you deserve love too, but you're making a case that because you deserve this
那不关你的事。你没有权利将你的道德强加于世界。你知道，我和我的许多治疗课程结束时，我只是告诉人们：“看，你正在证明你理应感觉更好，我绝对相信这一点，而且我认为你也理应得到爱，但你正在证明，因为你如此理应得到这些，你应该能够在不改变行为的情况下感觉更好。”而我不知道你该怎么做。我认为你必须决定是否要听我说的话，然后同意行为是一个问题。我们可能不知道如何改变它，但我们可以尝试很多工具，直到找到一个有效的，但你要求我改变你的症状，而你却不需要成长，也不需要改变你的思考、感受和行动方式。我做不到。我把这个决定留给病人。也许你不想这样做，那也没关系。这不是我的生活。你知道，我们不能一直以同样的方式行事，却期望感觉不同。你知道，我让我的病人决定他们是否需要我的帮助。
so much, you should be able to feel better without changing your behavior. And I just don't know a way that you can. I think you have to decide if you want to listen to what I'm saying and then agree that behavior is a problem. We may not know how to change it, but we can try a whole bunch of tools until we find one that does, but you're asking me to change your symptoms without you having to grow and without you having to change the way that you think, feel, and act. And I can't do that. And I leave that decision up to the patient. Maybe you don't want to do that, and that's okay. It's not my life. You know, we can't keep acting the same way and expect to feel different. You know, I let my patients decide if they want my help.
我正在变得越来越擅长让我的家人决定他们是否需要我的帮助。但其他人是否好转不应该由我来决定。在这个领域我并不完美。正直意味着我们对他人持有的道德标准，我们也应该同样地应用于自己，反之亦然。对于具有相同认知能力的人，不应该有不同的道德标准。所以要成为一个成年人，我们必须能够通过一致地将我们的道德标准应用于自己和他人来舒适地进行评判。这意味着我们必须评判
I'm getting better at letting my family decide if they want my help. But whether or not other people get better should not be my decision. And I'm not perfect in that sphere. Integrity means that the same ethical standard that we have for others, we should apply equally for ourselves, and vice versa. There should not be different moral standards for people with the same cognitive ability. So to be an adult, we have to be comfortable passing judgment by applying our moral standard to ourselves and others consistently. And that means that we have to judge
某些人身上那些让我们感到不舒服、让我们觉得评判他们很糟糕的部分。这意味着我们必须评判某些人身上那些让我们感到不舒服、让我们觉得评判他们很糟糕的部分。有时那种不舒服、糟糕、内疚的感觉会引导你面对自己的创伤和治疗。你害怕去的地方就是你以前受过伤的地方，如果你想好转，你就必须去那里。即使它发生在很久很久以前，你当时四岁，或者你不记得了，或者你当时13岁，如果你想改变，你仍然必须回到那里。所以这意味着你必须评判即使是我们爱的人，即使是那些我们宁愿为之找借口的人。即使是亲人身上那些我们宁愿不去注意的部分。如果你不能敏锐地注意到你的孩子或家人在哪里未能成长
the parts of some people that make us feel icky and make us feel bad to judge. And that means that we have to judge the parts of some people that make us feel icky and make us feel bad to judge. And sometimes that icky, bad, guilty feeling will lead you into facing your own trauma and therapy. Where you were afraid to go is where you were hurt before, and you need to go there if you're ever going to get better. Even if it happened a long, long time ago and you were four or you don't remember or you were 13, you still have to go back there if you want to change. And so that means that you have to judge even those that we love and even those that we would rather make excuses for. Even the parts of loved ones that we would rather not notice. If you can't discerningly notice where your children or your family are failing to grow
并保持真实，那么也许他们已经以一种不健康的方式成为了你自我的一部分。当你说“嘿，你儿子做错了事，你女儿做错了事”时，那些人会说：“哦，不，我只是认为你不知道。”好吧，你甚至没有听我说什么。你只是听到你的孩子做错了事，你就把你的孩子误认为是你自己了。所以你在解释他们怎么可能做错事。猜猜怎么着？你们两个都可以。如果你发现自己说诸如“但她来自不同的时代”或者“但，你知道，
and be authentic, then maybe they have become an extension of your own ego in an unhealthy way. The people when you say, hey, your son did something wrong, your daughter did something wrong. Oh, no, I just think that you don't know. OK, you haven't even listened to what I said. You just heard that your child did something wrong and you've mistaken your child for yourself. So you're explaining how they can't do anything wrong. And guess what? Both of you can. If you find yourself saying things like, but she was from a different time, or, but, you know,
但你不明白，或者也许如果你，你知道，去散个长步并建立联系什么的。”是的。你知道，如果地球上的每个人都坐在火堆旁进行一次深入的交谈，世界可能会看起来更好，我们会相处得更好。但这不会发生，因为有数十亿人。这是真的吗？不是。但也许有一个假设的情况可能会发生，这意味着其他人在同样的情况下可能会那样做，或者意味着也许，你知道，未来可能会有一个我能在脑海中想出的情况，比如有人会改变。好吧，太棒了。去上个写小说的课吧。关于这个人的说法是真的吗？是还是不是？这是真的吗？如果它是客观真实的，你知道，并且是真诚地给出而没有评判，而你只是无法
but you don't understand, or maybe if you, you know, took a long walk and got a connection or whatever. Yeah. You know, probably if everyone on earth sat down by the fire and had a long heart to heart, the world would look better and we'd get along. But that's not going to happen because there's billions of people. Is it true? Not. But maybe there's some hypothetical that could happen that would mean that everyone else might act that way in the same situation or would mean that maybe, you know, there could be a situation in the future that I could come up with in my head where like someone would change. Okay, great. Take a class on writing novels. Is what somebody said about this person true? Yes or no? Is it true? And if it's objectively true, you know, and given in earnest without judgment and you just can't
接受它，那么那是你的错。这也是你未能了解你是谁的失败。你知道，我们怎么能在不注意他们所有部分的情况下诚实地了解整个人呢？大部分成年人的现实归结为一个简单的二元对立。你宁愿舒适地生活在对现实的否认中，还是宁愿诚实地生活，即使这种诚实会引起你的焦虑？它会的。阿拉巴马大学的乔安·特雷尔，她教我伦理学，她是一位非常好的老师。她说，你知道，如果你对你在一个非常困难的伦理决定中做出的选择感到确定，
accept it, then that's your fault. And it's your failure to know who you are too. You know, how do we know the whole person honestly without noticing all their parts? Much of adult reality comes down to a simple binary. Would you rather live in denial of reality comfortably or would you rather live honestly, even if that causes you anxiety, that honesty? And it will. Joanne Terrell at UA, she taught me ethics and she was a really good teacher. And she said that, you know, if you feel certain about a choice you made in a really hard ethical
你就犯了一个错误，因为我们想说：“好吧，规则在这里，规则指引我朝这个方向走。这就是绝对的真理，非黑即白。”而那不是生活。你总是要处理相互矛盾的力量，你必须坐在那个灰色地带。如果你想变得诚实，你就必须坐在那种焦虑中。而那种诚实会引导你做出最好的决定。你知道，我们都宁愿生活在童年的近视舒适中，在那里所有让我们感觉糟糕的事情都是坏的。你知道，《狮子王》里的刀疤，他让辛巴感觉糟糕，因为他是坏人。
decision, you've made a mistake because we want to say, okay, here's the rules and the rules point me in this direction. And this is absolutely the truth, white and black. And that isn't life. You are always dealing with contradictory forces and you have to sit in that gray area. You have to sit in that anxiety if you're ever going to be honest. And that honesty will lead you to the best decision. You know, we would all prefer to live in the myopic comfort of childhood where everything that makes us feel bad is bad. You know, Scar and the Lion King, he made Simba feel bad because he was the bad guy.
我不知道《冰雪奇缘》那个。我知道我女儿看过。还有什么儿童电影？你知道，戒灵想要接管世界，索伦想要杀死地球上所有的生命。让主角感觉糟糕的事情就是坏的。但那不是成年人的生活。在成年人的现实中，一些让你感觉糟糕的事情只是
I don't know the Frozen one. I know my daughter's watched it. What's another child movie? You know, the Ringwraiths want to take over the world and Sauron wants to kill all life on Earth. The things that make the main character feel bad are bad. But that's not adult life. In adult reality, some of the things that make you feel bad are just
提醒你，你还不知道如何做所有事情，你并不完美，你需要改进一些事情。有些人的批评会让你感觉糟糕。而且，不幸的是，并不是所有让你感觉糟糕的事情都是坏的，这不是现实。那些让你感觉糟糕的事情中，有一些只是邀请你成长。人们可能会以一种有爱或无爱的方式向你提供这一点。我的病人告诉我他们感到被了解、被爱，并且他们欣赏治疗时刻的最频繁的时候，就是当我指出他们的自我欺骗正在发生时，我以一种有爱的方式指出他们在对自己撒谎。因为我希望他们既感到被诚实地看见，也感到被了解，即我知道那不是他们是谁。那只是他们选择做的事情，或者他们正在做的事情。
things that are reminding you you don't know how to do everything yet and you're not perfect and you need to work on things. Some people's criticism will make you feel bad. And, you know, unfortunately, it's just not reality that everything that makes you feel bad is bad. Some of those things that make you feel bad are just invitations for you to grow up. And people may offer you that in a loving or an unloving way. One of the most frequent times that my patients tell me that they feel known and they feel loved and that they appreciate a moment of therapy is just when I point out that their self-deception is happening, that they're lying to themselves in a loving way, I point it out. Because I want them to feel both seen, honestly, and also known, that I know that that isn't who they are. It's just what they're choosing to do or what they're
那些提醒你还没学会所有事情、你并不完美、你需要改进的事情。有些人的批评会让你感到难受。而且，不幸的是，让你感到难受的事情并不一定就是坏事，这并非事实。有些让你感到难受的事情，其实是在邀请你成长。人们可能会以友善或不友善的方式向你提出这些建议。我的病人告诉我他们感到被理解、被爱，并且感激某个治疗时刻，最常见的情况之一就是当我指出他们正在自欺欺人时，我以一种充满爱意的方式指出了他们在对自己撒谎。因为我希望他们既能感到被诚实地看待，也能感到被理解，即我知道那并不是真正的他们。那只是他们选择去做的事情，或者他们
doing right now. You need to make clear the difference between people's behavior and people's potential, you know, because they already feel like they are the behavior. That's why they don't want to look at it. And if you make them understand that they are their potential and their potential is solely up to them and whether or not they can ask and accept for help from themselves and others, you know, that's when there is change. So, you know, no one's flaws mean that they're undeserving of being loved. Not No one's. And it is that love that you use to invite your friends and family and patients to change when they're asking for it. self. You know, the places where parents failed us say nothing about us. More often, those are places where our parents stopped growing, and they refused criticism, and they could not heal past that point. And so they could not love the parts of themselves that is past the blank edge of the
现在正在做的事情。你需要明确人们的行为和人们的潜能之间的区别，你知道，因为他们已经觉得他们就是那种行为本身。这就是为什么他们不想去审视它。如果你能让他们明白他们就是他们的潜能，而他们的潜能完全取决于他们自己，取决于他们是否能向自己和他人寻求并接受帮助，你知道，那才是改变发生的时候。所以，你知道，没有任何人的缺陷意味着他们不值得被爱。没有任何人。正是这种爱，当你身边的朋友、家人和病人寻求改变时，你用这种爱去引导他们。你知道，父母让我们失望的地方并不能说明我们什么。更多时候，那些地方是父母停止成长的地方，他们拒绝批评，无法超越那个点去疗愈。所以他们无法爱自己内心深处那些超越了空白边缘的部分。
map. And they refuse to chart the rest of the map, and they don't know who they are. And they couldn't love themselves in that space. So of course, they couldn't love themselves in that space so of course they couldn't love you and that is not your fault you know we have the tools that we find or that are given to us as we're growing up and some people are given very few tools because their parents didn't have a lot to give them you know parents can't always come with us or even understand the places that we're going but that doesn't make growing up a bad place to go. It's perfectly acceptable and adult to admit that there are bad parts of good people. One of the reasons I like depth psychology is that it frees us from, you know, in interpersonal relationships, it frees you from bad guys and good guys or people who are, you know, bad and written off and people I won't
地图。他们拒绝绘制地图的其余部分，他们不知道自己是谁。他们无法在那个空间里爱自己。所以当然，他们无法在那个空间里爱自己，所以当然他们也无法爱你，这不是你的错。你知道，我们在成长过程中找到或被赋予了工具，有些人得到的工具很少，因为他们的父母没有太多东西可以给他们。你知道，父母并不总是能跟上我们，甚至无法理解我们要去的地方，但这并不意味着成长是一个糟糕的方向。承认好人身上也有糟糕的部分，这是完全可以接受的，也是成熟的表现。我喜欢深度心理学的原因之一是，它把我们从人际关系中的“坏人”和“好人”，或者那些被认为“糟糕”而被放弃的人，以及那些我根本不会去听的人，还有那些完美的、我听了很多的人中解放出来。
listen to at all and then people who are perfect that't listen to at all. And then people who are perfect that I listen to a lot. There are parts of us, you know, we've talked a lot about that. And I like Jungian psychology and the post-Jungian stuff that came from it, like internal family systems and all that, because it breaks people into parts and that helps us understand who we are with more honesty. And so with something like depth psychology, you can understand, you know, I don't have to cancel grandpa at Thanksgiving or lie to myself about who parts of who he chooses to be and still chooses to be and will probably always choose to be are. You know, I can say that I like these things about this person. I like their soul and I know who they are. And there's a place where they're not
我们谈论了很多关于这方面的内容。我喜欢荣格心理学以及由此衍生出来的后荣格学派，比如内在家庭系统疗法等等，因为它把人分解成不同的部分，这有助于我们更诚实地理解我们是谁。所以有了深度心理学之类的东西，你可以理解，你知道，我不必在感恩节时“取消”爷爷，也不必对自己撒谎，去掩盖他选择成为、并且可能永远选择成为的那部分人。你知道，我可以坦诚地说，我喜欢这个人的这些方面。我喜欢他们的灵魂，我知道他们是谁。但也有一些地方，他们并不
being honest and they're not being self-defeating. They're being self-defeating. They're running from who they are. They're being afraid and they're passing judgment in an insecure way. And I don't really like that part of him, but it's not my part to deal with. And it's not really my part to make him deal with unless he asked me for the help. And a lot of times when you're trying to find out if people want that help, you can just tell them how their behavior makes you feel. You know, when you do that, I kind of feel like I don't want to be around you because I just, I'm not able, you know, whatever it is, you know, and they can either attack you and say, well, that you should just get firm up and you're weak or that's outrageous. And then, you know, they don't want the help there. Or maybe they say, oh, I didn't
诚实，他们并不是在自我挫败。他们是在自我挫败。他们在逃避真实的自己。他们在恐惧，并以一种不安全的方式进行评判。我真的不喜欢他那一部分，但那不是我需要处理的部分。除非他向我寻求帮助，否则我真的没有义务让他去处理。很多时候，当你试图弄清楚人们是否想要那种帮助时，你只需要告诉他们他们的行为让你有什么感觉。你知道，当你这样做的时候，我感觉我不想和你待在一起，因为我只是，我无法，你知道，无论是什么原因，你知道，他们要么攻击你，说，你应该坚强一点，你太软弱了，或者这太离谱了。然后，你知道，他们并不想要那里的帮助。或者也许他们会说，哦，我不知道
know I was doing that. And you've got your foot in the door. A lot of people ask for help, but they're not really asking for help. The person is just like, why would he do this? Well, I don't know because you set him up to and then you enabled him and then you, well, why would you say that to me? That person is asking you for help, but they're not really asking for help. And then there's other people who are just like,
我在做那个。你就成功地打开了局面。很多人寻求帮助，但他们并不是真的在寻求帮助。那个人只是说，他为什么要这样做？嗯，我不知道，因为你纵容了他，然后你启用了他，然后你，嗯，你为什么要那样对我说话？那个人是在向你寻求帮助，但他们并不是真的在寻求帮助。还有其他人只是说，
I don't know why I feel this way. I mean, they're not saying help me, help me, but there's an openness to change. And I think that's what Adler means. He doesn't mean that you don't help anyone unless they walk up and say like, please, sir, may I have some help from you? He just means that you wait until people are open to growth and you continue to invite them there, but you can't force them there. You know, a long time ago, I had a patient in therapy and they told me, my boyfriend keeps cheating on me and I keep forgiving him. And I was like, well, could you not forgive your boyfriend? Like? Do you have the choice if he cheats on you to not forgive him? And they said, oh no, I couldn't do that.
我不知道我为什么会有这种感觉。我的意思是，他们没有说“帮帮我，帮帮我”，但他们对改变持开放态度。我想这就是阿德勒的意思。他并不是说除非有人走过来对你说“请先生，我能从你这里得到一些帮助吗”，否则你就不要帮助任何人。他只是说，你要等到人们对成长持开放态度，并继续邀请他们去那里，但你不能强迫他们。你知道，很久以前，我有一位治疗中的病人，他们告诉我，我的男朋友一直在欺骗我，而我一直在原谅他。我说，嗯，你能不能不原谅你的男朋友？比如，如果他欺骗了你，你有选择不原谅他的权利吗？他们说，哦不，我做不到。
I have to ignore the bad behavior and I have to take him back. Or I have to tell him I forgive him. And I told the person, you know, that's fine, but that is not what forgiveness is. That's just enabling because forgiveness is a choice. And if you can't not do it, then you're not doing something noble by doing it. You're just doing the only thing that you know how to do. You know, we should have grace and forgiveness for our own and others' mistakes. Judgment should not make you feel like a god by proxy. Forgiveness comes after honesty, though. You can't forgive me for the crime that I committed, and I'm still committing, and I plan on
我必须忽视这种糟糕的行为，我必须接受他。或者我必须告诉他我原谅他。我告诉那个人，你知道，这没关系，但那不是原谅的含义。那只是纵容，因为原谅是一种选择。如果你不能不原谅，那么你这样做并不是在做什么高尚的事情。你只是在做你唯一知道该怎么做的事情。你知道，我们应该对我们自己和他人的错误抱有恩典和宽恕。评判不应该让你觉得你代理了上帝。然而，宽恕是在诚实之后产生的。你不能原谅我犯下的罪行，而我仍然在犯，并且我计划
continuing to commit, because I haven't asked for help yet. That's not how grace works. Continuing to let somebody off the hook for behavior they refuse to change might make us feel less icky, but it also means that we don't have integrity. The best predictor of future behavior is always going to be past behavior. And if I will not admit that I have a problem, then I likely am not going to change, and you are within your rights as an adult to point that out to me. When people make objective statements of fact about you or other people, then that cannot, by definition, be mean or hateful. Unless they're cherry picking something just to hurt somebody, people putting reality out doesn't have a morality. Reality is just what it is. And then we, with the limitations
继续犯下去，因为我还没有寻求帮助。恩典不是这样运作的。继续让某人逃脱他们拒绝改变的行为的惩罚，可能会让我们感觉不那么难受，但这也意味着我们缺乏正直。未来行为的最佳预测指标永远是过去的行为。如果我不承认我有问题，那么我可能就不会改变，作为成年人，你有权向我指出这一点。当人们对你或其他人的行为做出客观的事实陈述时，那么根据定义，这不可能是刻薄或仇恨的。除非他们只是为了伤害某人而挑三拣四，否则人们陈述现实并没有道德问题。现实就是现实。然后我们，在这些限制之内
of that, try and figure out how to act within those limitations. And that is morality. You know, objective statements are just true or false. They can't be mean and they can't be hateful. And, you know, it's true that when those statements are about patterns or projections from someone's psychology, that's threatening, but it's still real. That's the way that they think. It's the way that they have demonstrated that they think and likely will continue to. And so one of the places where I see, you know, people have the hardest time accepting reality is when people point out honestly and without judgment, you know, the patterns and the preferences with which a friend or family member thinks and everyone else gets angry. And that happens in family therapy or the people who don't want that redirected at them or would rather enable somebody, they get
尝试弄清楚如何在这些限制内行事。这就是道德。你知道，客观陈述只是真或假。它们不可能是刻薄的，也不可能是仇恨的。而且，你知道，当这些陈述是关于某人心理的模式或投射时，这确实具有威胁性，但它仍然是真实的。这就是他们的思考方式。这是他们已经证明的思考方式，而且很可能会继续下去。所以，我看到人们最难接受现实的地方之一，就是当人们诚实且不带评判地指出朋友或家人思考的模式和偏好时，其他人就会生气。这种情况发生在家庭治疗中，或者那些不想被重定向的人，或者宁愿纵容某人的人，他们会
mad because they don't want to admit that those patterns are real. And patterns are one of the easiest things to ignore because, yeah, they did it yesterday, they did it the week before, they did it the month before, they've done it every week. But how do you know they're going to act that way in the future? That's so arrogant of you. Well, it's not because the way that psychology works is through these patterns and preferences, you know, on a very base level. So the things that you do, the values that you identify with, they say something about you. How could they not? You know, we don't pick our theology. We don't pick our philosophies. We don't pick our politics. We don't pick our personal beliefs
生气，因为他们不想承认这些模式是真实的。模式是最容易被忽视的事情之一，因为，是的，他们昨天做了，前一周做了，上个月做了，他们每周都这样做。但你怎么知道他们将来会那样做？你太傲慢了。嗯，事实并非如此，因为心理学的运作方式是通过这些模式和偏好，你知道，在非常基础的层面上。所以你所做的事情，你所认同的价值观，它们确实说明了你的一些情况。它们怎么可能不说明呢？你知道，我们不选择我们的神学。我们不选择我们的哲学。我们不选择我们的政治。我们不选择我们的个人信仰
randomly. We do that as a projection of our own psychology and our unresolved trauma. And you can't say, well, they were raised to or they were told to believe that or to let somebody off the hook. Because we have to be accountable for our own lives and the things that we do. And if there is an unhealthy, unconscious process in someone you love, then you're not being honest if you ignore it. You are enabling, and you're enabling yourself if you attack others that are simply pointing out facts that you want to ignore about other people. So if someone has become an extension of an unhealthy belief system, or if their actions become unhealthy because of something that they were told to believe, that is still absolutely that person's fault, and it is their responsibility to change it, because it can't be anyone else's responsibility. They are the only
随机地。我们这样做是我们自身心理和未解决创伤的投射。你不能说，嗯，他们被抚养长大或被告知要相信那个，或者让某人逃脱惩罚。因为我们必须对自己的人生和我们所做的事情负责。如果你的爱人身上存在一种不健康的、无意识的过程，那么如果你忽视它，你就不是在诚实。你是在纵容，如果你攻击那些仅仅指出你想要忽视的关于他人的事实的人，你也是在纵容你自己。所以，如果某人已经成为一种不健康信仰体系的延伸，或者如果他们的行为因为他们被告知要相信的东西而变得不健康，那仍然绝对是那个人的错，改变它是他们的责任，因为这不可能是其他人的责任。他们是唯一
one that can ask for help. They are the only one that can accept the help. They are the only one that can grow and change. No one else can do that for them. So who else's fault is that supposed to be? You know, our actions, our beliefs, our self-image, religious beliefs, you know, even or especially the modalities of therapy that different people pick, they're projections of our own psychology. You know, how could they not be? We pick them. If you're spinning your tires in the mud trying to justify intellectually something that you don't want to face emotionally, you're being avoidant and enabling. You know, these patterns are real. That's how I do my job. If you can't refute the truth of what someone challenging you is saying,
一个可以寻求帮助的人。他们是唯一一个可以接受帮助的人。他们是唯一一个可以成长和改变的人。没有其他人可以为他们做这件事。所以这应该是谁的错呢？你知道，我们的行为、我们的信仰、我们的自我形象、宗教信仰，你知道，甚至或者是特别是不同人选择的治疗方式，它们都是我们自身心理的投射。你知道，它们怎么可能不是呢？是我们选择了它们。如果你在泥潭里打转，试图在理智上为一些你在情感上不想面对的事情辩护，你就是在逃避和纵容。你知道，这些模式是真实的。这就是我做这份工作的方式。如果你无法反驳挑战你的人所说的话的真实性，
notice where your emotional self wants to say, yeah, but that's the beginning seed of avoidance that leads us to enable the brokenness of this world. It's what leads us to do and contribute to evil. And there are many more people It's what leads us to do and contribute to evil. And there are many more people, hundreds of people contributing to evil for every one person that actually does the material action. The other people are doing the avoidance that allows it to take place. So face this stuff. Watch your own reactions and notice where it is hard for you to not attack others when they state facts. That is where your psychology is still operating like a child's.
注意你的情感自我想要说“是的，但是”的地方，那是导致我们纵容这个世界破碎的逃避的种子。它导致我们去做并助长邪恶。还有更多的人，每有一个真正做出实质性行动的人，就有数百人在助长邪恶。其他人正在进行允许它发生的逃避。所以面对这些东西。观察你自己的反应，注意你在别人陈述事实时很难不攻击他们的地方。那就是你的心理仍然像孩子一样运作的地方。
And if you hear yourself making excuses for someone, when someone points out something that is simply true, then it's time for that part of you to grow up. Fighting evil starts with your ability to look into your own eye. Most religious traditions, they start when they're trying to challenge the ego, and then later they're co-opted by those that want to enable the ego and the self image as it exists right now, not what it could be. So, you know, don't misuse your own spiritual or philosophical tradition to this end. Really don't abuse your psychotherapy modality to that end, but that's a whole nother conversation.
如果你听到自己在别人指出简单的事实为某人找借口，那么是时候让你那部分成长起来了。对抗邪恶始于你审视自己眼睛的能力。大多数宗教传统，它们在试图挑战自我时开始，然后后来被那些想要纵容自我和现有自我形象的人所利用，而不是它可能成为的样子。所以，你知道，不要为了这个目的滥用你自己的精神或哲学传统。真的不要为了那个目的滥用你的心理治疗方式，但那是另一个话题了。
You know, in relationship counseling, the biggest predictor of success is not the size of the problem that the couple or the, you know, polycule or the family is facing. You'll see giant problems like drug addiction or serial adultery and that a couple heals from. And you'll also see small problems like avoidance and white lies that end a marriage. The biggest predictor of success is whether or not all parties are willing to accurately label the problem and agree that it should change. When you face your own shame, remember that it is not the size of the error, but the elaborateness of the defense mechanisms that you enable.
你知道，在关系咨询中，成功的最大预测指标不是夫妻，或者，你知道，多元关系或家庭所面临的问题的大小。你会看到巨大的问题，比如药物成瘾或连环通奸，而一对夫妇从中治愈了。你也会看到小问题，比如逃避和善意的谎言，导致婚姻破裂。成功的最大预测指标是所有当事人是否愿意准确地标记问题并同意应该改变。当你面对自己的羞耻感时，记住，不是错误的程度，而是你所启用的防御机制的复杂程度。
Evil is created when we rationalize and avoid labeling bad behavior so that we can insulate ourselves from the need to change. We all have the responsibility to change, and if someone willfully chooses to make themselves and the world a worse place, be honest about that fact. Defend their soul's potential, but not their behavior. Not even their behavior if it comes from trauma. And don't defend their refusal to actualize their potential. If somebody tells you not to speak ill of family or ill of the dead or, you know, a politician, a celebrity, tell them that you would rather be honest. If not authentic honesty, what else do we have?
当我们合理化并避免标记不良行为，以便我们可以将自己与改变的需要隔离开来时，邪恶就产生了。我们都有改变的责任，如果有人故意选择让自己和世界变得更糟，要诚实地面对这个事实。捍卫他们灵魂的潜能，而不是他们的行为。如果行为源于创伤，甚至不要捍卫他们的行为。不要捍卫他们拒绝实现潜能的行为。如果有人告诉你不要说家人的坏话，或者不要说死者，或者，你知道，政客、名人的坏话，告诉他们你宁愿诚实。如果不是真实的诚实，我们还有什么？
You know, really, what other personal freedom do we have? They all start with that one. Maya Angelou was a wise woman, but when she said, when people tell you who you are, believe them, she was talking about challenging your ego and the manners and the traditions that you were told made you noble and good, so that when you saw somebody act against your values, you understood who they were and you just let yourself know that. But a lot of these quotes about psychology get co-opted on Instagram and used to defend bad behavior. And one of Maya Angelou's that gets misused is, people don't remember what you said, they remember how you made them feel. Some variation of that will pop up on your Instagram. If somebody doesn't remember anything that you said and they
你知道，真的，我们还有什么个人自由？它们都始于那一个。玛雅·安杰卢是一位睿智的女性，但当她说，当人们告诉你他们是谁时，相信他们，她是在谈论挑战你的自我，以及那些被告知让你变得高尚和善良的礼仪和传统，这样当你看到有人违背你的价值观行事时，你就理解了他们是谁，并且你只是让自己知道这一点。但很多关于心理学的名言在Instagram上被利用，用来为不良行为辩护。玛雅·安杰卢的一句被误用的名言是，人们不记得你说了什么，他们记得你让他们感觉如何。这句话的某种变体会在你的Instagram上弹出。如果有人不记得你说的任何话，并且他们
think you are responsible for how they feel, they have a personality disorder. Write them off. Other people's emotional reactions to things that you didn't say because they can't remember are not your fault. Or things that you said as say because they can't remember are not your fault. Or things that you said as an objective statement that they turn into a subjective statement. That also is not your fault either. So stop quoting Maya Angelou on Instagram when you want other people to take responsibility for your emotion. Your emotional reality is your job. It is your job to remember and think about the points that others make, not to blame other people for how those points make you feel and then forget them. That is not what Maya Angelou
认为你对他们的感受负责，他们有性格障碍。把他们写掉。其他人对你没说的话的情感反应，因为他们记不住，这不是你的错。或者你作为客观陈述说的话，他们把它变成了主观陈述。那也不是你的错。所以当你想要别人为你的情绪负责时，停止在Instagram上引用玛雅·安杰卢。你的情感现实是你的工作。记住并思考别人提出的观点是你的工作，而不是因为这些观点让你感觉如何而责怪别人，然后忘记它们。那不是玛雅·安杰卢
meant. That is how her quote is used all over the internet. You know, I know that trauma plays a part in our beliefs about ourself and what we do. I know that it informs religion and philosophy and taste and culture. And I know that there informs religion and philosophy and taste and culture. And I know that there are reasons that people make the choices that they do, but we are the ones responsible for our own life and development. Ultimately, our lives are the sum total of our own choices. And as a friend, as a family member, as a therapist, you are not doing anyone a favor by pretending that that is not the case. Patients know that on some level, before they come to see you, that they want to grow. Even if they fight you during the growth process, they know that.
的意思。那是她的名言在整个互联网上被使用的方式。你知道，我知道创伤在我们关于自己的信仰和我们所做的事情中起着作用。我知道它影响宗教、哲学、品味和文化。我知道人们做出选择是有原因的，但我们是自己生活和发展负责的人。归根结底，我们的生活是我们自己选择的总和。作为朋友、家人、治疗师，你假装情况并非如此，并不是在帮任何人。病人在来见你之前，在某种程度上就知道他们想要成长。即使他们在成长过程中与你抗争，他们也知道这一点。
And ultimately, patients will leave if you fail to point out as a therapist that their life is their job. People come to therapy for many reasons, but underneath all of those choices, we are really only ever making one choice. Do you go into the parts of yourself that you're afraid of? Do you face them? And do you grow and change? Faced with that choice directly, most people will choose to run. And I understand the tragedy of that, but that does not
归根结底，如果你作为治疗师未能指出他们的生活是他们自己的工作，病人就会离开。人们出于许多原因来接受治疗，但在所有这些选择之下，我们实际上只做了一个选择。你是否进入你害怕的自己的部分？你面对它们吗？你成长并改变吗？直接面对那个选择，大多数人会选择逃跑。我理解其中的悲剧，但这并没有
make that decision or its consequences any less real. Most biographies are a tragedy, but that is not your fault. The only biography that you have control over is your own autobiography. Everyone has the ability to heal and change. You are not doing yourself or others any favors when you make excuses or make an argument that lack of growth is just part of someone's implicit nature. That's just how she is, or that's just how I am. No, it's not not that's just how you chose to behave and you can stop choosing to be that way if that makes you feel icky so sit with it and then go to therapy those people or you could change if you want to know you're
让那个决定或其后果变得不那么真实。大多数传记都是悲剧，但这不是你的错。你唯一能控制的传记是你自己的自传。每个人都有治愈和改变的能力。当你找借口或争辩说缺乏成长只是某人隐含天性的一部分时，你并没有帮到自己或他人。那只是她就是那样，或者我就是那样。不，不是，那只是你选择的行为方式，如果你觉得这让你感觉不舒服，那就去面对它，然后去接受治疗，那些人，或者如果你想的话，你可以改变。你知道你
not doing them any favors by indulging the belief that they can't change and in order to make them feel better telling them that that's just part of their nature and that we're all built different and that this is just something that implicitly is who they are. It's not. It's a choice. And you change if you want to. Maybe they don't want to, but don't pretend that they can. The parts of ourselves that defeat our authentic self should make us feel bad. And in order to feel bad enough to change, we have to feel that anxiety. That's why things like aa say you have to
并没有通过沉溺于他们无法改变的信念，为了让他们感觉更好而告诉他们那只是他们天性的一部分，以及我们都是不同的，这只是他们隐含的本质，来帮到他们。不是的。这是一种选择。如果你想改变，你就会改变。也许他们不想，但不要假装他们不能。我们内心深处那些击败我们真实自我的部分应该让我们感觉不好。为了感觉足够糟糕以至于想要改变，我们必须感受到那种焦虑。这就是为什么像AA这样的组织说你必须
hit somebody you have to let somebody hit rock bottom because when there's nothing else that they can blame for their situation except themselves then they have to look inward and a lot of times substance abuse will take away the ability to look inward because everything is outward faced with this survival of i cannot feel good on the inside, so I have to look outside for something that makes me feel good. And a ton of the time, you don't have the option not to do that in substance abuse until there's just nothing left. And that's why that concept exists. You know, that anxiety that propels us towards change, if we don't ignore it, if we don't turn it off, if we don't drug it, eventually it will help us
让某人触底反弹，因为当除了他们自己之外，他们没有什么可以为自己的处境责怪时，他们就必须向内看。很多时候，药物滥用会剥夺向内看的能力，因为一切都是向外的，面对这种“我内心无法感觉良好，所以我必须向外寻找让我感觉良好的东西”的生存状态。很多时候，在药物滥用中，你没有选择不那样做的余地，直到一无所有。这就是那个概念存在的原因。你知道，那种推动我们走向改变的焦虑，如果我们不忽视它，如果我们不关闭它，如果我们不给它下药，最终它会帮助我们
grow. But don't do the enabling thing by turning that anxiety off by telling other people that it's fine when it's not fine. You know, the reason that people who hurt you did that was because they were afraid to face their own fears. Your only choice is to face your own fear. When you don't believe that you can change, then constructive criticism is an attack because all the intonations of what you could be are a reminder that that is not who you are right now. If this is all that I think I can be, then all I can take from the most constructive of criticism is that what I am is wrong. It is wrong because I was made to believe that what I am is all I can be.
成长。但不要通过告诉别人“没关系”来关闭那种焦虑，从而做那种纵容的事情，当它实际上并不好时。你知道，伤害你的人之所以那样做，是因为他们害怕面对自己的恐惧。你唯一的选择是面对你自己的恐惧。当你认为自己无法改变时，建设性的批评就是一种攻击，因为所有关于你可能成为什么样的人的暗示，都在提醒你，那不是你现在的人。如果这就是我所认为我能成为的一切，那么我能从最建设性的批评中得到的全部就是：我现在的样子是错的。它是错的，因为我被灌输相信我现在的样子就是我能成为的一切。
In screenwriting, they have this concept that the antagonist cannot change. The protagonist changes, and the antagonist is somebody who gets stuck somewhere on the path to self-actualization, and they can't go past that point, so they try and stop other people who go past it or they attack them. The antagonist has no possibility of change. The shark from Jaws doesn't change. The alien from Alien doesn't change. The hitman in the country desert movie doesn't change. And as soon as they start looking inward, as soon as they start changing, then they are starting to become a co-protagonist in the movie. So, you know, when I start to change, I become the protagonist and everyone has that option. For real change to take place, the other party has to
在编剧领域，他们有一个概念，即反派不能改变。主角会改变，而反派是那些在自我实现道路上被困在某处的人，他们无法超越那个点，所以他们试图阻止其他人超越它，或者他们攻击他们。反派没有改变的可能性。《大白鲨》里的鲨鱼不会改变。《异形》里的外星人不会改变。《老无所依》里的杀手不会改变。一旦他们开始向内看，一旦他们开始改变，那么他们就开始成为电影中的共同主角。所以，你知道，当我开始改变时，我成为了主角，每个人都有那个选择。为了实现真正的改变，对方必须
understand themselves as a series of parts and decisions. You know, who they authentically are is not bad and they have to get that. Just because my behavior was bad does not mean that I am bad. Behavior is a choice and I can change. Most people will never know who they are, and that is a tragedy. They will never face the parts of themselves that they are afraid of, and in avoiding them, they will project them onto you and onto me. And this lack of self-awareness and self-discovery is a tragedy. You know, a tragedy that effective therapy, healthy spiritual practice, and loving families are seeking to remedy by expecting you to change and grow. If you refuse to change, then yeah, you are the bad guy. If someone chooses that, let that be their choice.
将自己理解为一系列部分和决定的集合。你知道，他们真实的样子并不坏，他们必须明白这一点。仅仅因为我的行为很糟糕，并不意味着我很糟糕。行为是一种选择，我可以改变。大多数人永远不会知道自己是谁，那是一个悲剧。他们永远不会面对他们害怕的自己的部分，在逃避它们的过程中，他们会把它们投射到你和我的身上。这种缺乏自我意识和自我发现是一个悲剧。你知道，一个有效的治疗、健康的灵性实践和充满爱的家庭正在寻求补救的悲剧，通过期望你改变和成长。如果你拒绝改变，那么是的，你就是坏人。如果有人选择了这一点，那就让他们成为他们的选择。
Let them be the antagonist. They could understand what you were saying if they wanted to understand themselves. You can absolutely invite people into growth and change in a loving way. Whether someone accepts that invitation is up to them. Their reaction says nothing about you. If you exist authentically with love and honesty, anyone's reaction to that is up to them. If they dislike your honesty, it is the same thing as somebody yelling at a mountain or a rainstorm. Maybe the weather or the terrain or honesty and convenience of somebody, but that is not your fault. That's just another part of reality that
让他们成为反派。如果他们想了解自己，他们就能理解你在说什么。你绝对可以用充满爱的方式邀请人们进入成长和改变。某人是否接受那个邀请取决于他们自己。他们的反应说明不了你什么。如果你带着爱和诚实真实地存在，任何人对此的反应都取决于他们自己。如果他们不喜欢你的诚实，这和某人对着山或暴雨大喊大叫是一样的。也许天气或地形或某人的诚实和便利，但这不是你的错。那只是现实的另一部分，
is being itself. So don't let yourself feel guilty if they are angry that you are honest any more than you would if somebody was yelling at the rain. You are only an advocate on behalf of reality and you will not win every court case. Reality is just what it is, and we all choose how to cope with that. Do your own journey, and let others choose if they want to do theirs. Beneath all of our choices, that is really the only choice that we make. Face yourself, or die, never knowing what you are. Hey there, I hope you enjoyed the article. Like I said before, you can always get on the www.gittherapybirmingham.com website and subscribe to other podcasts.
正在做它自己。所以如果他们因为你的诚实而生气，不要让自己感到内疚，就像如果有人对着雨大喊大叫，你不会感到内疚一样。你只是代表现实的倡导者，你不会赢得每一场官司。现实就是现实，我们都选择如何应对。走你自己的旅程，让别人选择他们是否想走他们的。在所有选择之下，那确实是我们做的唯一选择。面对你自己，否则就死，永远不知道你是什么。嘿，希望你喜欢这篇文章。像我之前说的，你总是可以登录 www.gittherapybirmingham.com 网站并订阅其他播客。
Look at the blog. Not all of the blog posts are turned into articles. Look at some of our free worksheets, some interesting ones on Jungian psychology, dissociative identity disorder, lots of stuff. I know that most of you are not in the Birmingham area and this podcast has probably not helped me find any therapy patients, but that isn't the point. The point is that you can learn about this stuff and we can find people who are on the same pathway somewhere hopefully good but at least
看看博客。并非所有的博客文章都被制作成了文章。看看我们的一些免费工作表，有一些关于荣格心理学、解离性身份障碍的有趣内容，有很多东西。我知道你们大多数人不在伯明翰地区，这个播客可能没有帮我找到任何治疗病人，但这并不是重点。重点是你可以在这里学习这些东西，我们可以找到在同一条道路上的人，希望是在好的地方，但至少
honest so uh please check out the website and i am almost embarrassed to admit this but uh we just did a long show about honesty so um i don't really want to monetize the podcast uh or anything like that but uh so many of the patients who come to our clinic have asked where we get our furniture and then bought furniture from Kardiel. K-A-R-D-I-E-L. Kardiel Furniture Company does a bunch of reproductions of modernist period furniture and then some new modernist inspired stuff. So many patients asked where we got it and then bought it that Cardio made us a brand rep. So if you do want to buy Cardio furniture that does support taproot therapy,
诚实，所以请查看网站，我几乎不好意思承认这一点，但我们刚刚做了一个关于诚实的漫长节目，所以我真的不想把播客货币化，或者类似的事情，但来到我们诊所的许多病人都问我们从哪里买的家具，然后从 Kardiel 买了家具。K-A-R-D-I-E-L。Kardiel 家具公司做了很多现代主义时期家具的复制品，还有一些新的现代主义风格的东西。很多病人问我们从哪里买的，然后买了它，以至于 Cardio 让我们成为了品牌代表。所以如果你确实想买 Cardio 家具，那确实支持了 Taproot Therapy，
you can use the promo code TAPROOT, all uppercase, I think, T-A-P-R-O-O-T. And you get 5% off. So if you want some modernist furniture and you're planning on buying furniture that you saw at our place, use the promo code TAPROOT to get 5% off at cardio.com. Thank you. And if you have any questions, send me an email. I look forward to hearing from you and signing off. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以使用促销代码 TAPROOT，全大写，我想，T-A-P-R-O-O-T。你可以获得 5% 的折扣。所以如果你想要一些现代主义家具，并且你打算购买你在我们这里看到的家具，使用促销代码 TAPROOT 在 cardio.com 获得 5% 的折扣。谢谢。如果你有任何问题，给我发电子邮件。我期待着收到你的来信并结束节目。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。